ja urlaub wird kompliziert und die lage
in der show branche ist auch nicht viel
besser
es gab eine demo da haben wirklich
künstler aber auch maskenbildner
fotografen doch auf ihr leid aufmerksam
gemacht und jemand der natürlich auch
davon betroffen ist er ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet nämlich entertainer matze
knop moderator comedian den kennen wir
und der mann macht einfach gute laune
hast du heute auch gute laune matze ich
habe heute sehr gute laune ich bin
nämlich hier gerade in köln
und zwar in der soccerhalle von lukas
podolski da haben wir für unseren
podcast messi und ronaldo mit calli mit
reiner calmund noch ein paar anderen
leuten tobi holtkamp der ja auch mal bei
euch war haben wir ein paar schöne
aussage gedreht also die stimmung ist
bei mir auf jeden fall sehr gut
und tatsächlich bist du auch betroffen
aber du hast glaube ich aus der korona
krise eigentlich das beste gemacht du
bist du mich jetzt auch sänger erzählen
uns darüber ja also ich muss wirklich
sagen für mich ist es sehr gut gelaufen
in dieser zeit ich hatte ja eine eigene
sendung bei sky matze knops home office
gerade in der zeit als der lockdown kam
und da habe ich dann diverse song
parodien sozusagen gemacht das war
einfach so eine eingebung ich dachte du
musst irgendwas am ende der show haben
was noch ein bisschen auflockert was
noch mal richtig lustig ist und gute
energie gibt und da habe ich dann
bekannte songs genommen unter anderem
warum hast du nicht nein gesagt von
roland kaiser und maite kelly habe
daraus gemacht ob ich noch einen wein
vertrag also quasi den song den man
wunderbar in der quarantäne spielen
konnte
und der ist mittlerweile von universal
gezeigt worden wie man so schön sagt und
ist auf dem ein händler darauf also ich
habe wenn man so will aus der not in dem
moment auch eine tugend gemacht
du musst aber auch zum teil ein bisschen
kleinere brötchen backen aus großen
hallen werden jetzt biergärten wie gehst
du damit um
also ich muss erstmal sagen natürlich
ist diese situation für manch anderen da
draußen deutlich schwieriger als für
mich für mich ist es bis jetzt habe ich
ja gerade schon gesagt einigermaßen gut
gelaufen und da bin ich sehr dankbar und
ich glaube dass dankbarkeit an der
richtigen stelle auch ein probates
mittel ist um sich in die gute energie
zu bringen ich glaube wenn man immer nur
auf das guckt was schlecht läuft dann
läuft es auch irgendwann schlecht ich
glaube man muss versuchen sich auf das
zu fokussieren
wo der wohnung positive energie ist dass
das mache ich das tue ich und der
biergarten ist ebenso eine kleine
biergarten turm eine normale tour wurde
quasi abgesagt aber biergarten steht für
mich jetzt an und ich war erst ein
bisschen kritisch ich dann mal gucken
wie das würd ich habe jetzt drei shows
schon gemacht und es war sensationell
die stimmung war richtig gut es hat mir
richtig freude gemacht ich war draußen
an der frischen luft die leute hat ein
richtig bock einfach mal wieder zu
lachen und ein bisschen zu feiern
natürlich im rahmen der möglichkeiten
und schon daher muss ich sagen eine
sache auf die wäre ich sonst nie
gekommen sind denn aus deiner sicht
künstler die sich jetzt zum beispiel
auch beklagen oder nach staatshilfen
schreien haben die alles richtig gemacht
oder verstehst du diesen druck und auch
jetzt wirklich den ruf nach hilfe ich
verstehe den druck total also ich habe
gesagt ich bin jetzt einer der auch im
fernsehen unterwegs ist ich bin eine
marke die schon relativ lange gibt also
matze knop oder manche offenheit noch
super richie an dass auf jeden fall
schon mal gehört aber so geht es ja
nicht jedem künstler und er hat auch
nicht jeder die möglichkeiten die ich
zum beispiel habe und deswegen stehe ich
total wenn der ein oder andere jetzt
gerade natürlich nicht weiß wie es
weitergehen soll und deswegen finde ich
das auch vollkommen legitim und wichtig
und dafür gibt es ja auch die
möglichkeit dass man in diesem unserem
land einfach auf der straße auch mal
seinen unmut oder oder seiner sorge luft
macht oder aufmerksam auf sich macht und
trotzdem glaube ich ist das nur eine
sache die man machen sollte die andere
ist eben dass man trotzdem sich auf das
fokussiert was gut läuft in einem
eigenen geschäftsleben dann ist es
glaube ich immer gut wenn man anfängt
flexibel zu sein also neue wege geht die
man vielleicht bis jetzt noch gar nicht
in betracht gezogen hat und was auch
wichtig ist man ist natürlich künstler
und wir sind hier alle künstler geworden
weil wir es lieben frei zu sein und
trotzdem ist es ein geschäft und ich
glaube geschäft sind zu entwickeln ist
auch ganz wichtig und das sollte man
unabhängig davon tun dass man vielleicht
sagt mensch der staat soll mir helfen
wir diskutieren da gleich weiter wir
haben einen o ton von der künstler demo
von herbert grönemeyer und schauen noch
mal rein
vielleicht nicht die maschine und der
motor deutschland aber wir alle zusammen
sind die rauschende seele wir sind der
öffentliche herzschlag dieser nation und
unseren teams und kunst sind unser puls
von unsere adern ohne euch sind wir
genug leer und sind leer
intercell mayr herr scholz das sprechen
will ich übernehme sie haben denn sie
wollen sie endlich los ist direkt massiv
ein land stellt sein zauber aufs spiel
um seine zauberer zu disposition und
weiter hört ja klare aussage unterstützt
du diese forderungen auch absolut also
da hat er was er da gesagt hat absolut
recht mit weil es geht ja auch nicht nur
um den künstler also der der auf der
bühne steht es geht auch um die ganzen
menschen die dahinter sind es geht um
die veranstalter es geht um die
techniker ohne die wir das hat er
wunderbar gesagt natürlich sonst auch in
kein mikrofon sprechen könnten
und deswegen ist das ist auch mein
ansporn übrigen dass ich nicht nur was
machen damit es mir besser geht sondern
damit auch den menschen besser geht die
in meinem umfeld sind und er hat
natürlich absolut recht dass die politik
da auf jeden fall handeln muss und zwar
schnell das ist das eine und das andere
ist auch gewinnbringend also das bringt
ja nix wenn man jetzt in misano kannst
den kredit aufnehmen und dann macht das
eine und dann ist es in einem jahr aber
immer noch nicht besser und dann ist ja
noch mehr in der schuldenfalle drin also
damit ist dann auch nicht geholfen man
muss sich schon genau überlegen was
hilft den künstlern und das hat der
kollege grönemeyer ja auch sehr gut
gesagt dass ich glaube kunst oder kultur
oder comedy und musik das ist einfach
ein großes stück leben und das macht das
leben ja auch finde ich schön
und da sollte man da sollten auch die
politiker nicht sagt achten das ist
nicht so wichtig doch das halte ich für
sehr sehr wichtig lachen ist gesund das
ist ein slogan den ich wirklich liebe
und ich hoffe dass man da die richtigen
entscheidungen trifft und eben nicht so
lange warten sondern zügig ich nehme an
kempkens mit dazu der hat aufmerksam
zugeschaut tatsächlich bekomme ich als
sagen wir notleidender künstler jetzt
die möglichkeit einen günstigen kredit
aufzunehmen lindert das ja auch nicht
unbedingt meine lage wie sehen sie das
champions
ich glaube auch dass matze knop zurecht
kult-komiker auf den ich schon immer
gestanden habe und ich finde ganz
richtig dass er sagt positive energien
also positiv denken positiv nach vorne
denken und neue wege denn das ist auch
das was wir rechtsanwälte genau
empfehlen das zu machen eben nicht so
nach hinten zu schauen sondern auf den
weg zu schauen der vor uns liegt nämlich
jetzt wird sich etwas verändern ist wird
sich nachhaltig und langfristig etwas
verändern und deswegen meine ich der
status quo darum geht es gar nicht so
sehr sonne es geht darum dass wir neu
angreifen neuen ideen entwickeln und
genau das ist der punkt und das können
wir aus anwaltlicher sicht nur sagen
denn alles was sozusagen in den bereich
kredit geht und stundung von forderungen
und so weiter geht das ist ja nur ein
aufgeschoben das problem und das problem
bläht sich immer mehr auf und das sehen
wir in der praxis dann auch man kann
eine weile dann überwintern
aber es funktioniert dann eben nicht
deshalb muss man sich einfach neu
positionieren und deswegen kann ich das
nur 11 unterschreiben
matze du hast ja tatsächlich uns erzählt
wie du dich da auch weiterentwickelt hat
und neu erfunden hast ist es denn dann
richtig wenn der staat einfach dann die
kassen aufmacht natürlich kann jeder
künstler sich tatsächlich auch selbst
weiterentwickeln und sich vielleicht
auch selbst am schopf aus dieser misere
ziehen oder muss der staat jetzt für
alles da stehen ja ich denke das habe
ich ja eben schon gesagt beides also auf
der einen seite ist es ja so dass die
menschen in diesem land diese politiker
gewählt haben und ich sage so ich habe
ja nun auch fans zuschauer die in meinem
publikum die also die da sitzen und
zuschauen wenn ich komme die macht und
die haben ja mich in dem moment gewählt
und wenn die mich gewählt haben dann
möchte ich denen auch etwas zurückgeben
weil die haben eine karte gekauft und
dann können die von mir auch was
erwarten
und so würde ich mir dass man von
unseren politikern auch ein bisschen
mehr wünschen und nicht dass sie so was
machen die denn da und die soll immer
still sein sondern sich einfach mal
sagen mensch das sind eigentlich meine
leute die haben dafür gesorgt dass ich
überhaupt hier sitze das ist das eine
und das andere ist und das finde ich
mindestens genauso wichtig dass man
trotzdem das ganze in die eigene hand
nimmt und dass man sagt das ist eine
option
aber ich verlass mich nicht allein
darauf sondern ich gebe selber gas ich
gucke wo sind die möglichkeiten was habe
ich noch nicht ausprobiert ich gehe
runter vom sofa ich gucke auf die guten
sachen und wenn mir was passiert dann
nicht dankbar ich kann auch ständig
darüber lamentieren wenn ich ein
knöllchen bekommen habe ich gestern
wieder bekommen aber vielleicht habe ich
am selben tag hat mir einer zwei tassen
kaffee ausgegeben und das vergisst man
dann und wenn man ich glaube in diese
richtung so ein bisschen mehr anfängt zu
denken dann glaube ich dass es für einen
selber auch als künstler vielleicht
schon relativ schnell ein bisschen
besser läuft ja klare aussage von matze
knop und an kempkens ist ein großer fan
das heißt es ja fast ihren fantreffen
matze bleibt so wie du bist bleibt so
optimistisch sie die sachen genauso wie
du sie sie ist alles gute auch für dich
und natürlich auch alles gute für die
ganze branche
dankeschön